Fight!
You are literally blowing into a fan, there(!)
Lego with a hat.
It's an origami toad.
That's pretty advanced for this competition.
Versus, er... Baby Bl... oh, bloody hell!
I don't know which side the crowd
will be on in this one.
We have beautiful, hand-made,
crocheted robot...
...versus a toilet.
Piloted by someone from
actual Robot Wars...
No way you come out of this looking good, mate.
No matter what!
Lost a wheel, there's a wheel gone there -- oh!
Oh, koala-bot is gone!
So our grand final...
Will Tictac and Pingu
please take to the stage!
2! 1! Activate!
6! 5! 4! 3! 2! 1!
The winner has to be: Tictac!
For your astonishing efforts
despite failing immediately, I award you...
this box!
And the prize for the winner of Hebocon UK
at Electromagnetic Field 2016
and a very deserving winner,
please give it up
for Tictac!
That was Hebocon, we hope you enjoyed the show,
good night!
Thank you to our film crew,
thank you to all the roboteers,
thank you to Jim for running everything
I'm going to get out of this tuxedo.
Good night!
[Translating these subtitles? Add your name here,
and please translate the captions into the empty boxes.]